day two of Live with Kelly Ripa and Mark
Consuelos starting off a bit rough it's
the number one show in daytime don't
want to screw that up yeah Kelly suffers
a mini wardrobe malfunction while
dancing with guests Val shmirkovsky and
Jenna Johnson
okay no just a little bit it's just a
breakaway dress just this oh that was
awesome okay
do you want to who cares you can't
overthink it it's just a live TV show
the TV personality totally plays it cool
finishing off the choreo like a champ
well so far I've torn my dress that's
what dance is all about yeah good okay
take it off
married couple Kelly and Mark made their
live debut as co-host Monday morning
joining me today and permanently until
one of us dies is Marcus
I mean Mark's been filling in here I've
been here for almost 23 years he's been
filling in for that long
um so it's been a long time you told me
just to be myself yeah enjoy the moment
um one show at a time just like we
always do and the pair is definitely no
stranger to working together we've
always worked together in some capacity
we run a production company together we
start on a soap opera together we run a
sitcom together we've always had
different jobs together are we lucky or
what those hours are much longer those
were 12 hour days those were you know
every day every day yeah the duo spent
plenty of time together well you got
your a team here and Kelly Ripa that's
correct you know what I mean by Tom
Brady making Mark a great choice for the
network as long time host Ryan Seacrest
retired from the role a source selling
ET they wanted to avoid her and the new
co-host not hitting it off and with the
two already sharing the screen in the
past it's always gone well with fan
reaction so I just want to be hopefully
value added to the show Ryan spent six
years alongside Kelly but when it came
to passing the torch he says he didn't
need to impart any tips Mark just need
advice he's been he's he's spent believe
this or not more hours with Kelly than I
have he's the only man on the planet
that's done that
um he's gonna be great and I'm so
excited for both of them no turning back
now
ask for what viewers can expect
talk show we won't go home and like
discuss oh what should we talk about
tomorrow because that's not how we do
things here it's more of a spontaneous
discussion between two people that have
had a full day outside of just
discussing host chat like we'll see
we'll we'll split off right after this
and I'll see you at dinner time will
there be anything that is off limit sure
yeah
what's off limits Mark
she's very good I think it'll change
from day to day yeah yeah it'll change
from dating Kelly is there anything for
you that's awesome of course not nothing
is ever awesome yes I'm an open book and
if you don't read me fast enough I'll
read myself out loud to you
foreign
[Music]